it is seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast and these are our top stories
the mothers grieving their sons murdered
by russian forces we'll bring you the
story of peace street near butcher
and i'm in ukraine where the fighting
continues and president zielenski says
he has lost up to 3 000 troops in the
conflict so far
not fit for purpose concerns over the
visa process for ukrainian families
waiting to come to the uk
also ahead the home secretary's formal
instruction to press ahead with plans to
send asylum seekers to rwanda despite
objections from her top civil servant
calls for routine screening for a common
infection which can prove fatal in
newborn babies
in the sport liverpool and manchester
city meet for the second time in six
days this afternoon as the fa cup
reaches the semi-finals
as for the weather a fine day in store
with warm sunny spells for many once the
overnight fog lifts the rain spreading
into western ireland later
and at quarter two we'll take another
look at the papers with the former
editor of the daily star john neeson and
the writer and academic mo lovett
[Music]
morning all ukraine is bracing for
renewed assaults after moscow threatened
to step up missile attacks on the
ukrainian capital after the sinking of
the moskva russia's flagship in the
black sea well last night a senior u.s
defense official said the ship had been
hit by at least one ukrainian missile
let's take a look at the latest
developments police in ukraine say the
bodies of more than 900 civilians have
been found in the area around the
capital after russian forces withdrew
from the region
ukrainian authorities say russian
shelling hit a residential area of
kharkiv on friday killing at least 10
people including a seven month old baby
and injuring 35
others in his nightly address to the
country president zielenski has said as
many as 3 000 ukrainian troops have died
during the war so far
and the mother of a british man captured
by russian forces whilst serving in the
ukrainian army has told sky news he
should be treated as a legitimate
prisoner of war jason good to see you
hopefully your connection's working okay
just bring us up to date with the latest
uh president zielinski
claiming that perhaps as many as 3 000
ukrainian troops have been lost i mean
the key phrasing in that statement so
far
yeah that's right he says between two
and a half and three thousand ukrainian
troops have been lost uh and that
obviously compared to the number of
civilians that the mayor of mario paul
said uh so far uh he believes being
killed that just in that city uh at a
figure of 21 000 and as you said in your
introduction they've found
900 civilian bodies now in and around
kyiv so it is predominantly civilians
who are the casualties of this war and
that is why there were
celebrations really here in of certainly
a feeling of celebration here in odessa
when the moskva was sunk out in the sea
which had been patrolling off the shores
of this city because it was seen as a
great threat sending
missiles
into this area and others and
people feel that um that that really is
something uh to celebrate they one
person said to me you know this isn't
the sort of thing we would actually be
very happy about people dying at sea um
but
russia is killing our civilians killing
our children
it's not clear yet what impact that is
going to have on
the russian military it's clearly a big
dent to their prestige it is a
catastrophic naval incident for them but
they still have other warships they're
still able to blockade this city
and they've proven that they can still
fire missiles in and cause damage and
kill people we heard of those 10 people
dying in kharkiv there were another five
people died up the road in mikolai of
here where that ship was actually built
back in the soviet era when some
shelling came into the civilian area
there injuring lots of people as well
and perhaps the most immediate direct
response to what happened from russia
was the bombing of a factory uh just uh
outside of kiev which actually built
these kind of missiles built uh air
missiles and naval missiles that factory
was bombed uh you know almost directly
after the sinking of the ship so that
seems like an immediate uh response but
i'm sure
we will see more
and uh i think you know that this this
city and others are still bracing
themselves for this
big push
and
again asking the west what more they can
do to help support them
and interestingly there was a
diplomatic message from moscow to the us
on tuesday which has only just been
revealed today in the washington post
and the new york times
saying to the west that there would be
unpredictable consequences if they did
continue to supply weapons to ukraine i
mean it's a it's a kind of phrase we've
heard before
from moscow but it was interesting
because it came just before president
biden approved another 800 million pound
package to ukraine and military support
including for the first time long
missiles and it brings to a total from
the us uh in in terms of financial
support of military aid to three billion
pounds so i think russia feeling that
this is becoming a bit of a proxy war
between
russia and the west
and trying to threaten the west to say
look you've got to stop supplying arms
here but if they do it's difficult to
know how the ukraines would be able to
defend themselves that said the neptune
missile that allegedly sunk this boat
was developed here
in ukraine
jason many thanks indeed uh just a
little bit of breaking news in fact
reaching us from ukraine's capital kiev
around about four o'clock our time this
morning there were reports on the news
wires of explosions being heard in and
around kiev uh the mayor of kiev of
course vitali klitschko the former
professional boxer
has said that rescuers and medics are
now working on the site of that
explosion in what he describes as kiev's
outskirts we'll try and
monitor events there and see if we can
bring just a little bit more detail on
what might have happened but certainly
it feels like there may well have been
some sort of a cruise missile attack or
perhaps an attack from the air will
monitor and return to that uh but let's
also return to that report from our uh
security and defense editor deborah
haynes she has traveled to a street in
kiev known as p street and has been
speaking to two mothers of two sons
killed and tortured
by the russians before her report just a
warning it does contain distressing
accounts of torture
when russia's war hit this small village
outside kiev it took the heart out of a
single road
p street
two young men grew up together here a
few houses apart
victor ballet in the yellow t-shirt
pavel koladenko in the
white now two shattered families are all
that's left
they say russian soldiers captured
tortured and shot the childhood friends
their broken bodies found buried
together in a shallow grave
the local priest the only comfort
of
she clung to the memory of her only
child
victor and pavel both used to serve in
the military it's probably why they were
murdered
she last spoke to her son in late
february when russian tanks rolled into
the village
the two friends had been planning to
volunteer to fight again
as we spoke pavel's mother appeared
she showed us their house
and her raw pain
[Music]
and do you believe that your son and his
friend were
captured and tortured and killed
together
um
photographs of pavel remembered fondly
he and victor were only 28 years old
no one knows what day they died
their remains only found after russian
forces withdrew
the priest helped give them a proper
burial
he showed us pavel's final resting place
a permanent reminder of what russia's
war did to the two young friends from
peace street
debra haynes sky news said
outside kiev
uh well let's get the latest assessment
now from the former head of policy
planning at nato fabrice pottier fabrice
good to see you again hope you're well
um i wonder if we might start with uh
that which we've just been hearing in
the past a few hours from president
zielinski speaking to cnn in an
interview with with that particular
channel he suggests that we need to be
mindful of the fact that vladimir putin
has nuclear weapons and that he might
use them is that a little bit of
posturing by the ukrainian president or
is this the reality that we all must now
deal with
well i think from the beginning putin
was kind of clear that nuclear weapons
were pretty big in the background of
this office war campaign uh so i think
what the ukrainian president just said
is not nothing fundamentally new but
obviously uh very serious uh and of high
concern
but should not freeze uh the efforts by
by the west to actually help the
ukrainians prevail on the battleground
so so i think we should not fall into
the vladimir putin nuclear blackmail and
instead
should stand firm uh ascend to put in
some clear message then uh
wmds have no place in this conflict and
keep on supporting the ukrainians
what what then of the the situation in
the black sea the flagship being lost
there there are some there is a bit of
debate between the ukrainian position
that they shot it and it went down and
the russians who claimed that afar broke
out but but either way it's a
significant loss
this is very significant very symbolic
uh and and you have to keep in mind that
in three weeks putin wants to have his
big parade on the 9th of may uh on on
the red square and and i figure we'll
have to show some some symbolic and some
real victories
and this is why probably now we are
seeing an escalation uh of the uh
russian forces and also of the russian
threats because he will have to show
more than what you're just saying on
your screen which is one of the most
symbolic uh battleships of the russian
navy
that got sunk most probably by ukrainian
forces
what what does this then mean for this
pending assault that we were all
predicting at will happen in the east of
the country
it means a terrible uh war of
destruction of an inhalation of of
entire cities
uh and and possibly population areas
like we've seen mariupol so you may have
mario paul reproduced on on
different fronts on the on the eastern
donbass and and the real question here
is can we provide uh zelensky and his
forces enough heavy equipment especially
artillery and
counter artillery systems to be able to
resist uh the onslaught that's the real
question
well what do you make of the the chances
of that i mean of course we had that
nato meeting a little bit earlier a few
days ago now in which they agreed to
start providing that the heavier
armaments the heavier weaponry so there
is definitely the the desire to help in
that capacity but but even with that
just the numbers that the russians have
massed on the borders the numbers that
they can mobilize quite quickly
i mean it was a bloody battle at the
very least
it will be and then look at mario paul
the ukrainians are still resisting
inside mayupol
and and yet uh the the russians are
willing to entirely destroy uh the city
and and with the strategy probably that
if they win they will win on the on on
the field of runes and then they will
maybe repopulate uh mario paul with
their their own kind of russian uh uh
population and it's deeply disturbing
because this is the kind of thing you
saw during the second world war
especially in ukraine
but i think you can predict this kind of
strategy and the only way again is to
contain as much as possible the russian
and onslaught and to keep on basically
protecting major population centers in
western ukraine including kiev but also
odessa and other ones to show that
ukraine is not going to fall under the
russian pressure this is really
important
and one of vladimir putin and his
position or the security of his position
in in the kremlin i mean barely a week
goes past without another report of some
senior figure within the russian
administration perhaps a military
adviser perhaps a civil servant you know
finding themselves you know suffering
from a poison attack going missing
having an unexplained heart attack
well i think this is a pattern we are
familiar with sadly and uh
i will not read too much into it in
terms of oh this is the weakening of the
putin's campaign in ukraine i think he
will be willing to throw everything he
has
to somehow prevail enough so that he can
uh claim victory
what victory looks like
or success looks like for him can change
uh and like for example now he has
clearly uh abandoned the aim of getting
a kiev over taking care of and now the
focus is much more in eastern ukraine
but what a victory in success looks like
is going to be very important uh to make
that war uh uh possibly uh uh coming to
an end in a way that does not destroy
the entire ukraine and doesn't
disseminate its population
fabrice always good to see you febreze
potato thank you so much for joining us
now some of the day's other news now and
campaigners are calling for routine
screenings in pregnancy of a common
infection in adults which can prove
fatal in newborns two babies on average
develop group b strep infection in the
uk every day one of those sick babies
will die every week with another
survivor left with long-term
disabilities the government says there
is currently insufficient evidence about
the benefits of universal screening but
we'll keep it under review
one of the terrorists behind the 2015
paris attacks has apologized to his
victims in court salah abdassalam told
the court he'd changed his mind before
detonating his suicide belt and said he
wanted to express his condolences and
offer an apology to all the victims
abduslam is the only surviving member of
an is cell which killed 130 people
including 90 at the bataclan theatre
new research says thousands of cancer
patients in england face distressing
waiting times due to missed targets
after the coronavirus pandemic
according to research from the house of
commons library 78 of patients between
november and february waited longer than
two weeks to see a consultant after an
urgent referral from their gp
that means nearly 200 000 people waited
longer than the targeted duration
palestinian officials say that more than
150 people have been injured in clashes
with police at the al-aqsa mosque in
jerusalem joining us now our middle east
correspondent alistair bunkel from
jerusalem good to see you this morning
alastair because we were talking around
about the same time about the events in
and around the al aqsa mosque how has it
been since then
well it has been a lot quieter
thankfully since then uh we were
watching out for potential violence last
night potentially around the damascus
gate uh on the edge of the old city
where uh palestinians like to gather
during ramadan for iftar to break the
ramadan feast it's been particularly
last year it was the scene of a lot of
trouble between palestinians and israeli
police but all quiet last night after
the events of yesterday morning no less
tense though i should say there's a lot
of diplomacy i think going on behind the
scenes the egyptians were reportedly
speaking to hamas the group that
controls gaza and could be quite
influential in what happens next and the
egyptians were also speaking to the
israelis as well clearly relaying
messages between them uh hamas
reportedly have
put down a number of demands they've
said that they want everybody who was
arrested yesterday to be released uh
they want muslims to be able to worship
in peace in the al-aqsa compound both of
those i think are possible
but they've also asked that the israeli
defense forces cease their operations
around the west bank town of janine i
don't think that is likely i think
they've got unfinished business there so
we'll see what happens on that front and
the u.s state department as well clearly
showing the concern within the upper
echelons of the american political
system saying that they want peace as
well in jerusalem
alastair thank you
the united nations refugee agency has
raised concerns about the uk's proposal
to send
some migrants who arrive in britain on
small boats to rwanda the un saying it's
a breach of international law sky news
understands the home secretary was
forced to issue a ministerial direction
over the scheme that's a formal
instruction for it to go ahead despite
objections from her most senior civil
servants our political correspondent rob
powell has the detail
what this means is that the top civil
servant in the home office so a
non-political official has flagged up
concerns as they see it about the plan
to reset the people in rwanda now we
don't have the precise details of what
those concerns are but they're usually
about value for money
or feasibility or whether they just
don't have enough data to conclusively
say whether the plan will work or not in
response to that pretty patel has
basically issued an instruction to say
that officials should basically go ahead
and implement the policy anyway that
means she's accountable
for it now you don't get many of these
ministerial directions there's only been
about 46 um in the last decade they were
issued quite a bit during the pandemic
for things like the bounce back loan
scheme where there was a risk of fraud
but a need to get money out quickly and
also eat out to help out and what
sources in the home office say
specifically about the rwanda
resettlement policy is the reason that
this has had to happen it's just because
it's quite a new novel policy and it's
very hard to quantify the impact it will
have and hence put a number on how much
money it could potentially um save
crucially these directions don't mean uh
that civil servants are against the
policy but it does show that there are
concerns even within the department and
it also shows that there's a large
degree of uncertainty about whether this
will actually work now for critics of
the rwanda plan i think they will see
this as further evidence as they see it
anyway of a flimsy plan that could cost
lots of money but i think for those that
are more sympathetic to the idea
they will see it
as a case really of advisors advise and
ministers decide and probably praise the
home secretary for pushing through with
something that she believes can deliver
results
rob powell there time for us to have a
quick look at your weekend weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
uh more fine warm and sunny weather to
come this easter weekend however it will
turn cooler with some rain by monday
most places will enjoy a dry start today
with overnight low clouds mist and fog
patches especially towards wales and
southwest england the low clouds and fog
will lift and clear to warm sunny spells
although parts of scotland
might just stay fairly cloudy at
temperatures reaching into the low 20s
and parts of england and wales but it is
worth noting the pollen levels are going
to be pretty high today
thicker cloud and outbreaks of rain will
spread across western ireland this
afternoon reaching northwest scotland
later ireland northern ireland and
western scotland will be cloudy and wet
overnight elsewhere it should stay dry
with clear spells and some fog patches
for much of britain easter sunday
looking to be fine with some
increasingly hazy sunshine however
western scotland northern ireland and
the republic will be cooler cloudier and
wetter and it turns cooler on monday as
that cold front sweeps south eastwards
across the country bringing some rain
a month after the uk's ukraine
sponsorship scheme was launched
thousands of sponsors are still waiting
to welcome ukrainian refugees to their
homes tens of thousands of applications
have been received by ukrainian families
but so far only a fraction have arrived
in the uk the refugee council says it
shows a visa system is not fit for
purpose as sky sanya chaudhary reports
inundated with donations limet is ready
to host a ukrainian family but nearly a
month after signing up she's frustrated
at what she says are hoops and hurdles
in the sponsorship scheme
you fear between
total
anger
and wanting to scream at somebody
to being on the verge of tears
getting the home up to council safety
standards has been grueling she's been
asked to drain her garden pond add
restrictors to windows and board over
glass panel doors
hi
inna
how are you
not being able to track the application
has made the weight worse
you can order some balloons from china
and you can track it and you know where
it's coming from you know where it is
you can
generally tell when it will be delivered
you cannot track these visa applications
there's no way that the family can track
them you just have to wait
more than 55 000 applications have been
submitted to sponsor ukrainian nationals
fewer than half have been issued with
visas and just six percent of the
refugees have arrived to the uk
frankly it indicates that a visa system
is not fit for purpose in responding to
a humanitarian crisis because what it
does is it builds in delay it builds in
bureaucracy and it builds in more human
suffering
for vanessa the process to get jana and
her daughter ira here took three weeks
and with the conflict still raging there
is some joy
i cried at the airport
[Laughter]
yeah it's lovely it's really lovely to
know that um they're both safe
and they're living here and they're in
our house and we can do this good thing
the refugees minister has promised to
simplify the visa process and says the
uk is on track to processing cases in 48
hours
sardia chowdhury sky news
the mother of a british man captured by
russian forces in ukraine has told sky
news he should be treated as a
legitimate prisoner of war aidan aslan
was serving as a marine in the ukrainian
armed forces when they were forced to
surrender in the besieged city of
mariupol his captors have since released
photographs of him appearing to have
suffered head injuries sky news has
chosen not to show those images in line
with the geneva convention which says
that prisoners of war ought to be
protected and humanely treated but this
report by fraser mods does include a
previous interview we did with aidan
whilst he was fighting on the front line
just hours before surrendering to
russian forces in the besieged city of
mariupol aidan aslin sent this message
home to his family in newark
if you're watching this it means that
we've surrendered
we've lasted about a month run out of
ammunition
food
the only thing we had left was water
the next time the family of the former
care worker saw him was on a video
broadcast by russian state tv which
claims he's a mercenary a video which
sky news has chosen not to broadcast
they have put him on their tv so
he is now
he is alive
that they are now accountable his family
say aiden who has applied for ukrainian
citizenship joined the ukrainian army
four years ago and as such should be
treated as a legitimate prisoner of war
he's not a mercenary he's not a
volunteer he did not go out there
in the last month to think i'm gonna
fight i'm gonna get glory he has been
out there for four years
um
and
he is a legit ukrainian
marine
aiden spoke to sky's stuart ramsey
shortly before his unit became
entrenched in mariupol he wanted the
world to listen
i don't think we need to send british
troops or american troops i think all
the west needs to do is we need to
support ukraine politically like give
them as much political support as we're
doing like continue even like amp it up
and just give them the weapons they need
to defend themselves and to defend their
country
ayden's family have contacted the
foreign office for help to secure his
release and hope that he could be part
of a prisoner exchange between ukraine
and russia
whatever route he takes they just want
him to be able to return safely to the
hero's welcome they believe he deserves
fraser moored sky news newark
well let's get the latest on the ground
from the ukrainian capital kiev now and
speak to svyatislavurash at ukrainian mp
in fact ukraine's youngest mp i'm told
thank you so much for uh joining us this
morning um
first and foremost i'm just wondering
what the situation is like in and around
kiev at the moment we've been hearing
reports of explosions on the outskirts
of italy klitschko's suggesting that
medics are on the ground do you know any
more about what has been happening over
the past few hours
kiev continued to receive rocket attacks
by cruise missiles from russia even
though we defeated the russians around
kiev and pushed them back across the
border but the truth is that as far as
kiev's concerned uh we always have a
threat of russians coming back and
trying to seize our capital but we are
well and ready from the first days of
the war we turned here into sydney that
is uh able to withstand all as we've
shown in the fighting of the last month
in kiev
do you then feel that the capital is
impenetrable is impact impregnable by
the russian forces they do possess the
ability of course to attack from uh from
a long range which is what we assume has
happened on the outskirts
they attack from the long range
they attack from aircraft they have been
firing rockets non-stop even though they
were pushed back across the border and
they were defeated around kiev but as
far as the
situation and what we expect russians
have shown that they are willing to use
anything and everything to try and
subjugate our country and again we
should resist no matter whether it's
kiev or khaki or anywhere else in
ukraine
what have you yourself um been doing i
mean
our viewers will not know this but i
understand that you've been
certainly very active on social media
you've certainly been trying to to rally
you rally your fellow ukrainians behind
you but you've also been receiving as
other men of kind of under 60 have been
doing in ukraine receiving your military
training
i have been mobilized i have become part
of 133rd battalion and basically that
this was
around fighting
around kiev and now awaiting orders from
my commander to move further east in the
meantime let's try to maintain
logistical operations to try and receive
our humanitarian support that i'm
sending out to the towns in need and we
are preparing a humanitarian mission to
the east at the moment at the same time
we're also trying to help the press and
i have some people who are involved with
foreign legion
just in terms of of the assistance that
your country has been receiving of
course it was only a couple of days ago
that boris johnson made that surprise
trip to to the capitol and vladimir
zelinski certainly spoke very warmly
about the assistance that the uk and
others have have been providing but i
suspect that there is no end to the
request that ukrainians will have for
heavier weaponry additional armored
vehicles and so on
it's also
the matter of the uk leading the way as
far as western support or western
understanding or the fact that ukraine
is a test case for national law working
or not so the point here is that uh uk
taking this leading position is
continuing in the proud tradition that
the the
united kingdom has always had in trying
to lead the world to adjust to outcome
no matter the no matter the uh travails
on the way
but as far as the requests we have yes
the truth is the russians are preparing
something massive in the east and they
are trying to do that to showcase that
this all was not a failure and they will
have at least some victory to present uh
we are determined to push them back and
to fight till the very end no matter
which part of ukraine it says the
capital or the east so yes nothing is
enough all is welcome
i think that there are certainly those
of us in the west who have been hugely
impressed by the by the fortitude by the
strength shown by the ukrainian people
we have also been utterly shocked by the
scenes of devastation that we've seen in
places like mario paul
i mean when this conflict comes to an
end as as it must at some point how much
of your country do you think will be
left
the truth is that
that we don't see this scope of what's
happening mario mario was a town a half
million people and last journalists with
that uh were thrown out or actually
there were several they were killed in
madrupal itself so the horrors of bucha
and horrors of the territories
uh that it was we liberated around kiev
is just the beginning because what you
will see as we liberate more and more of
our country is horror that russia is
imposing on everyone living here but the
fact of the matter is that this conflict
will take as much as russia
is willing to throw at us because again
for us there is no question here we're
fighting for our very existence for our
future as independent country as
independent nation so it doesn't matter
what russia throws at us we must fight
we must resist sweaters love yours thank
you so much for joining us really
appreciate your time thank you very much
okay with us once again to review the
papers the former editor of the daily
star don neesom and the writer and
academic mo love it ladies good to have
you all again um we're pushed for time
some more let's let's jump straight on
into your story from the sun words we do
not want to hear from the russians that
they already view this as world war
three
yes i mean obviously none of us want
world war three i think this is an
interesting story this comes about
because of the um the sinking of the
flagship um
ship in the black sea uh that russia
have now um or certainly a host of a um
media uh channel russia one which is
backed by the kremlin of course we know
that have described this as an
escalation into world war three and say
they are now fighting nato
infrastructure that is not necessarily
fact as we know there's a lot of um a
lot of propaganda coming out of both
sides but particularly in terms of the
russian side but it's interesting that
they've gone from calling this a
strategic military operation in ukraine
to suddenly upping the ante i mean it is
let's face it a major um embarrassment
for the kremlin that this ship has been
sunk and there's been a devastating loss
of lives as well of course um but the
very fact that this is this ship was
sunk i mean it's the first time i think
since the japan war of
1905 um that such a catastrophic um uh
disaster has hit the the russian navy um
but obviously syrian embarrassment for
the kremlin and and the the prop the
point of this ship is that it was there
to protect other ships it was kind of
the lead ship within the black sea
operation so it is a major embarrassment
so this is probably why they've come out
with this kind of fighting talk but
obviously as you say neil none of us
want an escalation in the language or
indeed the material reality on the
ground um so yes another turning point
in the war i think um let's hope i mean
there's already been one retaliation i
think from russia in bombing and missile
factory uh just outside kiev as a result
of uh
in kind of retaliation for this thinking
but it's very worrying when we hear
sorts this sort of language coming out
of kremlin sponsored tv stations yeah
and it'll also be interesting to see how
the kremlin responds to that i think
it's the story in the times this morning
about special forces at being involved
on the ground as well um uh but don can
you take us to the front of the daily
mail and and they seem to be getting
quite annoyed about this that civil
servants you know the staff in up and
down whitehall are have adopted a hybrid
working model i thought that was what we
were supposed to all be aiming for these
days
well i think we're all a bit confused
and and firstly it does feel weird that
i'm not with you in the studio now but i
do understand there's training order
however this is been an exclusive
investigation they have got the licks in
a twist about this one but just two days
a week in the office for civil servants
um
thousands of mandarins i mean who uses
that word in your life but thousands of
mandarins are now allowed to work from
home a male audit of a typical era
monday in march
many public funded bodies had less than
10 of their staff in work some only 5
and 1 none at all now when you consider
how hard some departments in particular
the doctors and nurses working for the
department of health in the front line
are working
it's a bit it's a bit much that some
people are still actually working from
home and they're getting allowance
allowances to work from home as well
they get loans to buy desks and things
like that now
look there are there are enormous
benefits to working in office especially
if you're a young employee and also it
supports satellite businesses like
sandwich shops and hospitality industry
and cities as well and it's all very
well if you're uh a higher up civil
servant if you're a youngster starting
out new and you're living in cramped
accommodation working from home just
can't be surely a good thing and surely
it's all time to get back to work
yeah i think i think there were plenty
of people agreeing with you this morning
and mo take us though inside at the
daily mail interesting uh kind of
marginal by-election coming up in
wakefield and an interesting name doing
the rounds as a potential conservative
candidate oh in fact he'd have to change
his name from lord frost back to david
frost in order to stand
yeah i think this is really juicy bit of
gossip neil um yeah page 10 of the mail
tories are urging lord frost to stand in
wakefield by-election uh and as you say
he can actually because of a change in
the rules in 2014 he could actually come
out of the lords uh in order to stand
and i think the idea is that he's very
popular particularly with brexit voters
um and um and the tories in general he's
very statesmanlike um he's a
professional man he's a serious man
whether you agree with his politics or
not he's certainly um seen as a very
serious politician so um and this is
what the tories think they need in the
wakefield by-election uh let's remember
this is one of these red wall talking
seats that turned from labor
a long-term labor seat up until 2019
when when the tories uh took it from
labor i mean i suspect it i think it's
an interesting piece of gossip and i'd
really like to see david frost return to
frontline politics um i think it's
probably a bit of a risky bet for him um
because it it's not um necessarily clear
that the tory is particularly high in
the polls at the moment in this stage of
the election cycle um so it could be a
risk too much for uh lord frost and he
may play it safe and and stay in the
lords why wouldn't he i guess um but
it's certainly an interesting bit of
gossip and i do think we want to watch
this space and see if lord frost is
tempted by a return to the commons
i suspect we will soon find out don
you've got 30 seconds to tell us why
two-thirds of britons want the prime
minister to resign f
how many parties are too many parties
that's the big question on our minds at
the moment um 55
of brits two-thirds of britain's
actually when boris johnson out if he
gets any more party fines obviously it's
already been fined 50 quid for being
ambushed by a birthday cake i remember
rightly um along with rishi and um and
the misses i have a name probably forgot
so any case they've already had one time
but we think that if he gets fined more
then he should be out and he should
resign and interestingly 55 of us also
think that rishi should resign and rishi
i thought thought he'd more or less got
away with the one party and only 14 of
us now think that boris is telling the
truth about he didn't know what a party
was hmm still one in four think he
should remain in row even if he does get
more fines which is another way of
putting the headline on the story at don
moe we will be back for round three uh
just before it just before nine o'clock
we will see you then
but you can stay right where you are we
will have more at from ukraine in the
past few minutes we've been hearing from
the mayor of kiev vitaly klitschko
suggesting that there has been an
explosion on the outskirts of the
capital at the southeastern district on
kiev on the left back of dinique we will
have more of that after this
[Music]